Now that we've uploaded a few screens,
let's make a click-able
prototype out of them.
To do this, simply click on any
screen within your project.
This will bring us
into the console mode.
The console mode has four
options at the bottom.
Preview, build, comment,
and history mode.
For this section, we'll only focus
on the preview and build mode.
Click on the build mode to begin
creating prototype hot spots.
In the build mode, go ahead and
use your cursor, and drag and drop.
Over an area of your image
to create the hotspot.
This will open a window where you can
choose the destination for that hotspot.
You can choose a gesture or
a transition.
Once you've created that hotspot,
go ahead and hit Save.
And to preview whether or
not this interaction works,
I'm going to go back to the preview
mode and there you have it!
I've just created
the very first hotspot.